好 那今天这堂课是要跟大家简略的介绍Diffusion Model的基本概念
其实Diffusion Model有很多不同的变形
以下的说明主要来自最知名的Denoising Diffusion Probabilistic Model
大家常常提到的DDPM
今天其实比较成功的那些用Diffusion Model做的影像生成的系统
比如说Dali或者Google的Imagen
或者Stable Diffusion
基本上都是用差不多的方法
来作为他们的Diffusion的model
好 那这个Diffusion model
是怎么运作的呢
运作的方法是这样子的
我们来看它是怎么生成一张图片的
在生成图片的第一步
是你要去sample一个
都是杂讯的图片
就是你sample出一个
从Gaussian distribution里面
你也sample出一个vector
这个vector里面有的数字
这个vector的dimension
跟你要生成的图片大小
是一模一样的
假设你今天要生一张256
乘256的图片
从normal distribution
sample出来的那个vector
它的dimension就要是256乘256那么多
那就把你sample到的那个256乘256的vector
排成一张图片的样子
然后接下来你就有一个Denoise的module
Denoise的内容
那等一下会讲说这个Denoise的内容内部长什么样子
这个Denoise的内容从它的名字里面就可以知道说
输入一张都是杂讯的图
那输出它就会把杂讯滤掉一点
那就可能看到有一个猫的形状
然后再做Denoise
那猫的形状就逐渐出来
那就Denoise越做越多
越做越多
期待最终你就看到一张清晰的图片
那这个denoise的次数是事先定好的
那我们通常会给每一个denoise的步骤
给它一个编号
那产生最终图片的那个编号比较小了
那一开始从完全都是杂讯的输入
开始做denoise的编号比较大
所以我们这边就从1999一直排到2排到1
那这个从杂讯到图片的步骤
它叫做reverse的process
在概念上这件事情
其实就像是米开朗基罗说的
雕像其实本来就已经在大理石里面
它只是把不要的部分拿掉
Diffusion Model做的事情就是一样的
本来图片就已经在杂讯里面
它只是把试作杂讯的部分把它滤掉
就产生一张图片
好 那以下我本来是想用Me Journey
把这句话的意境呈现出来
后来发现其实有点困难
我直接把这句话丢到Me Journey里面
他就画了一些雕像的半成品出来
就ChangeBT有一个专门把Pump改成Me Journey
可以吃的Pump的咒语
然后生一下看起来是这个样
看起来是不太行
然后后来我决定自己手动输入
然后我输入的句子是类似
有一个大胃像在石头里面
但是看起来Mit Journey还是没有很懂这个意境
他没有办法画一个大卫像在石头里面的感觉就想说他可以画一个有点透明的石头然后里面有一个大卫像看起来我Quant的功力非常的弱没有办法让他画这件事情你如果看这个Me Journey的那个Discord
里面的人都画出来的图
都让我看为观止
非常地羡慕
每个人都是涌唱大师
所以我涌唱的技巧还非常地不纯熟
没有办法把我心中想要表达的意境画出来
好
那接下来就要讲Denoise的model了
那从这个图上看来
你可能会想说这个Denoise的model
是不是同一个呢
是不是同一个Denoise的model
反复用很多次呢
是我们这边是把同一个Denoise的model
反复进行使用
但是因为在这边每一个状况
你输入的图片差异非常大
在这个状况你输入的东西
就是一个纯杂讯
那这个状况你输入的东西
它杂讯非常小
它已经非常接近完整的图
所以如果是同一个模型
它可能不一定能够真的做得很好
所以怎么办呢
你这个Denoise的model
它除了吃要被Denoise的那张图片以外
它还会多吃一个输入
这个输入代表
现在Noise严重的程度
然后1000代表刚开始Denoise的时候
这个时候Noise的严重程度很大
然后一代表说
现在Denoise的步骤快结束了
这个是最后一步Denoise的步骤
那显然杂讯很小
那这个Denoise的model
希望它可以根据我们现在输入
在第几个step的资讯
做出不同的回应
所以这个是Denoise的model
所以我们确实只有
用一个Denoise的model
但是这个Denoise的model
会吃一个额外的数字
告诉它说
现在是在Denoise的哪一个step
那Denoise的module里面
实际内部做的事情是什么呢
在Denoise的模组里面
它实际上有一个Noise predictor
这个Noise predictor做的事情
就是去预测说在这张图片里面的杂讯
长什么样子
这个Noise predictor就吃这个要被Denoise的图片
跟吃一个Noise现在严重的程度
也就是我们现在进行到Denoise的
底几个步骤的代号
然后就输出一张杂讯的图
他就是预测说
在这张图片里面
杂讯应该长什么样子
再把它输出的杂讯
去剪掉这个要被
Denoise的图片
然后就产生Denoise以后的结果
所以这边Denoise的model
并不是输入一张有Noise的图片
输出就直接是Denoise后的图片
它其实是产生一个输入的图片的杂讯
再把杂讯扣掉输入的图片
来达到denoise的效果
那你可能会想说
那为什么要这么麻烦呢
为什么不直接认一个
ant to an的model输入
是要被denoise的图片输出
就直接是denoise的结果呢
你可以这么做
那我在文献上也看过有人这么做
不过现在多数的论文
可能还是选择任一个Noise的predictor
因为可以想想看
产生一张图片跟产生Noise
它的难度是不一样
如果你今天你的Denoise muscle
可以产生一只带杂讯的猫
那它几乎就可以说它已经会画一只猫了所以要产生一个带杂讯的猫跟产生一张图片里面的杂讯这个难度是不一样的
所以直接认一个 noise predictor
可能是比较简单的
认一个 anti-read model
要直接产生 de-noise 的结果
是比较困难的
接下来的问题就是
怎么训练这个 noise predictor
我们已经知道
我们一个 de-noise 的 model
是一个 noisy 的 image
然后吃一个现在在Denoise的step的数目
的step的ID
然后产生Denoise的结果
我们又告诉你说
其实Denoise的module里面是一个noise的predictor
它是要吃这张图片
吃一个ID
然后产生一个预测出来的诈讯
但是你要产生出一个预测出来的诈讯
你得要有ground truth
我们在训练内卧的时候
你就是要有pair data才能够训练
你需要告诉noise predictor
这张图片里面的杂讯长什么样子
它才能够学习怎么把杂讯输出出来
那这件事情怎么做呢
怎么制造出这样子的资料呢
这个 Noise Predictor 它的训练资料
是我们人去创造出来的
怎么创造呢
它的创造方法是这样
你从你的 database 里面拿一张图片出来
你自己加噪音进去
就 Random 从 Gaussian Distribution 里面
sample 一组杂讯出来
加上去
产生有点 noise 的 image
那你可能再sample一次
再得到更 noisy 的 image
以此类推
最后整张图片就看不出来
原来是什么东西
你把你的手上的
有的照片都做这样子的事情
这个加噪音的过程
叫做 forward 的 process
又叫做 diffusion 的 process
那做完这个 diffusion process 以后
你就有 noise predictor 的训练资料了
怎么说呢
对Noise Predictor来说
它的训练资料就是
这一张加完杂讯的图片
跟现在是第几次加杂讯
是内卧的输入
而加入的这个杂讯
就是内卧应该要predict的输出
就是内卧输出的光数
所以你在做完这个diffusion的process以后
你手上就有训练资料了
你就告诉Noise Predictor说
看到这张图
看到第二个step
输入二这个数字
你要输出是什么
你的光处就是一个
这个样子的noise
接下来就跟训练一般的内容一样
train下去就结束了
但是我们要的不只是深图而已
刚才讲的好像是
只是从一个杂讯里面深出图
还没有把文字考虑进来
要怎么把文字考虑进来呢
在下一页后影片
就会讲怎么把文字考虑进来
但是在讲怎么把文字考虑进来之前
需要先让大家知道的事情是
如果你今天要训练一个影像生成的模型
它是吃文字产生图片
你其实还是需要成对的资料
你还是需要图片跟文字成对的资料
需要多少成对的资料呢
在我们的作业6里面
我们其实没有叫大家从文字生图片
只有直接生图片而已
那我们的资料是七万张图
那七万张图当然非常的少ImageNet它是每一张图片有一个类别的标记还不是那个图片的描述不是像Cat in the snow这样图片的描述
它只是每一张图有一个标记
然后它有100万张图片
我们先用这个圆圈的大小来代表图片的数量
我告诉你今天这些
你在网路上看到的非常厉害的
什么Meat Journey
Stable Diffusion
或者是Dali
他们的资料往往来自于Lion
Lion有多少image呢
5.85 billion的图片
有58.5亿张的图片
所以如果你把图片的数量
换算成有原色的圈圈的话
ImageNet你可能以为已经很大了
Lion有这么大
有这么多图片
所以难怪今天这一些模型
可以产生这么好的结果
Lion其实有一个搜寻的demo的平台
你可以去裡面看看它裡面有什麼樣的圖片
那裡面真的是啥都有
比如說貓的圖片呢
它不是只有貓的圖片跟英文文字的對應
它還有跟中文的對應
還有跟日文的對應
所以就知道說
為什麼今天那一些影像生成模式
不是只看得懂英文
你給它中文它八成都也看得懂
那是因為它的訓練資料裡面
也有中文跟其他的語言
你可以事实上在里面你找得找得到自己的照片
我是试一下我是找不到自己的照片
蛮多名人的照片
比如说川普那个随便一找就一大堆
所以你也不用意外说
为什么那个Me Journey都画得出川普
因为他就是知道川普长什么样子
所以这个是你需要准备的训练资料
好那有了这个文字跟影像成对的资料以后
我们先来看一下Denoise的时候
你是怎么做的
Denoise的时候你的做法非常的简单
把文字加到Denoise的模组就结束了
所以现在Denoise的模组不是只看输入的图片做Denoise
它是根据输入的图片加上一段文字的叙述
去把Noise拿掉
所以在每一个step
你的Denoise的模组都会有一个额外的输入
这个额外的输入就是你要它根据这段文字的叙述
生什么样的图片
好
那这个Denoise module里面的
Noise predictor要怎么改呢
你就是直接把这段文字
给Noise predictor
就结束了
要让Noise predictor
多一个额外的输入
也就是这段文字
就结束了
好
那训练的部分要怎么改呢
你现在每一张图片
都有一段文字
所以今天你先把这张图片
做完Diffusion的process以后
你在训练的时候
不只要给你的noise predictor
加入杂讯后的图片
还有现在step的ID
多给一个就是文字的输入
然后noise predictor
会根据这三样东西
产生适当的noise
就这样
产生要去消掉的noise
产生这个光处
这个就是DDPM完整演算法的algorithm
从它原始论文里面直接结出来的
就这样
没有更多东西了
就这样子
然后但是这两个LGISM里面其实还是暗藏一些玄机
这个我们就留着下次再跟大家讲